[Musik]
china einstellen times haben müssen um
zu probieren
ohne einen cocktails zwei cockpits die
bremse für uns ein sehr emotionales
thema mit ein paar für leuchtet
mitbekommen wir sind ein bisschen an
branchen auftritt auf instagram unsere
gefühle sind durcheinander unsere
geschäftswelt hat sich komplett
verändert denn wir haben die welt der
chinesischen drama entdeckt chinesischen
brothers chinesischen farmers day gehe
also die chinesen wissen auf jeden fall
wie man love stories aufbauen und wir
sind völlig drin ja weg ja und es gibt
so vieles worüber wir reden möchten ja
und wir halten
ich versuche all meine freunde zu
überbringen musste gucken
neben es ist zwar anstrengend die
untertitel zu werden ihr müsst wissen es
gibt nicht mal eine übersetzung sollten
wir vielleicht dazu
die serie ist chinesisch und gelesen
coach auf deutsch vor
die mental kranke menschen wirken auf
alle da draußen bevor wir gleich
anfangen die product placement in dieser
serie dr
die sind so es ist so wirst du stars
nichts wird es hätte kein youtuber
schlechter hinlegen können als dafür
damals galt wird für mich immer so ich
liebe dich ja ich hab's wieder schöpft
indirekt gesagt das spiel ich bin schon
auf ein zwanzigstel und ein kreuz und
eine minute wie sie dieses spiel soll es
gibt ein statement wenn sie natürlich
die jungen leute immer der waren hängen
ja ballantine's heißt es die betriebe
gerade rauszufahren ich musste gucken
mal die zutaten und checken wie es
schmeckt phallus geschmack ein hauch
vanille eine auch immer hier leben auch
noch nie wieder in meinem leben ich das
was ich sowieso nicht wie du das
hingekriegt ist ja weil sie auch nicht
25 so und das pokerface man hat
anscheinend gut funktioniert denn ich
will unbedingt mal ballantine's
probieren diesen disco ja weil sie dabei
sind einfach 100 mal da trinken ja in
einer folge bestimmt also immer eine
placement hat funktioniert deswegen
gibt's heute auch nur zwei cocktails
über ein ganzes formate zur liebe vom
wintergarten umgeschrieben
so kompliziert drei cocktails 2 ich weiß
nicht was heute passieren vielleicht
explodiert alles nicht irgendein budget
also und mp nach dem benutzen bentheim
und es sollte schon so thema haben -
repräsentieren und ja es muss auf jeden
fall die leidenschaft der serie
orientiert und auch parat oscar für ein
paar vorderleute versuchen es nicht aber
ganz ehrlich wer da draußen wird diese
serie kung lao probiert einfach
bescheuert im kopf aus einem grund also
ich kann mir aber dort und wärmstens
empfehlen ich finde hier sollte ich die
gucken nur ein bitte mach den instagram
account volkmer und schreibt mir und
komfort auf wikipedia findet man von den
rängen und den anderen den war also der
macht nämlich eigenes instagram und ich
war nicht so oft draußen ich auch
verstehen und wissen wir ja mal die
seite von google über das motorrad ist
außergewöhnlich schmetterlings höhe des
fliegens die rede wenn du in jaffa
sprachen so wunderschöne das steht immer
das mit blumen und irgendwie auch nicht
verstehst nach kelly weist in dem wir
zusammen sind
am liebsten berlin
ja aber ich ein bisschen verstört wenn
du so viele märkten hat sich also ich
habe einen energy drink in pink
grapefruit geschmack eine limette
einlegen war der nur 6 cent ricosta und
bohnenkraut bestens geeignet für bohnen
gewinnsucht ist ein boot and fraud super
für wohnen gericht da habe ich letztens
erst gelingen
ich habe mir falls du haben und kanals
in ihrem haus und dann brauche ich noch
als talent sondern machte ich mir
eigentlich könnte ich kenn dich
valentines mit acht köstlichkeiten
machen weil sie ja immer schaffen
mit acht köstlichkeiten essen aber 1 2 3
4 5 6 und dann völlig okay also ich sag
jetzt mal machen zutaten wie ich gekauft
habe
du hast nicht achtet ohne 2 346 7
meine nummer
hey was jetzt ernsthaft mich aber was
ist das für eine nummer die wir aktiv
ich muss natürlich eine ananas und jeder
der meteor garten gesehen hat weiß
ballantine's mit acht köstlichkeiten
natürlich muss eine zutat ananas sein
okay google spiele meteor garden ok
google spieledienst track von nitraten
auf spotify ok google nicht das hobby
[Musik]
ich liebe dich und nicht mehr die augen
treiben
das habe ich schon acht mal sogar das
ist kocht jetzt machen wir eröffnen
da ist niemand an meine 18 taten
[Musik]
das merkst du dich die honig motor die
lustlose sheikh hassan das nicht stimmt
ich werde ich wenn ich nicht super
korrigieren könnte
diestandard.at brauchst du eine matte es
ist tupperware auch super adler
japanischen schule haben jetzt mal
wirklich ans eingemachte
also die dramatische szene hat zwar
keinen lieblings also okay ich heute
anders beim werk 18 da machst du geweint
[Musik]
das ist auch schon folgerichtig wenn ihr
jetzt das nicht gespeichert haben wollt
dann müsst ihr auf diese minute klicken
ja eher von einem 40 obwohl hat ihren
letzten tag zusammen verbracht haben und
noch zusammen essen
in london verabschiedet
ich saß da auf der couch ich saß so was
hast du dir solar steht hier also der
moment mich wirklich gefreut ich glaube
ich habe 40 minuten lang zufolge durch
geräusche wahr als daran wieder
auseinander und dann war
ley und shenzhen vom bus und haben auch
einen bus gewartet weil sie in die
arbeit musste und dann kam aber doch
normal und hat seine liebe charmant ist
sie aber trotzdem in den bus einiges weg
gefahren und mehr als diesen bussen
slomo hinterhergerannt
und dann ich habe immer nicht mehr als
voll anfang habe ich aufgehört habe
gefahren ist und dann ist es so langsam
verschwunden und er ist ja wohl was ich
mich echt auch gewundert habe weil in
diesem für diesen kommunistischen
chinesischen lifestyle machen die schon
viel somit wissen wir und wie einer
hauptfigur saftig eine unabhängige frau
hier auch mal sagt sony das gibt mir
alles gegen den geist und dann sorgt sie
dann machst du da ich habe ihm geglaubt
damit automatisch
ja sogar automatisch am besten ist es
eigentlich wenn man die schale noch
brandl ist und durch diese irgendwo wird
die bitterkeit und das schmerzt mein
lieblingscharakter ist china aber warum
eigentlich ein irdisches hab ich weiß
nicht mehr so denn dort muss ich sein
ich finde ja auch optisch einfach sehr
ansprechen ich wusste nicht dass ich
auch so ein typ mann stehe aber
anscheinend schon nägel finde er auch
optisch einfach sehr ansprechen
pauli
ronnenberg
[Musik]
nach liebe ist man ja auch oft sehr
bitter wie diesen leben ohne grüne
zitrone limette sollten
das ist es muss auch bis zum rand voll
sein weil manchmal hat man auch hat sie
auch wirklich den avant voll okay also
brust bevor du bist du einfach nicht ich
muss sagen jaja das bohnenkraut tut sein
bestes um er irgendwas tut gar nicht ich
glaube dieser drink schmeckt so wie sich
meine liebesleben anfühlt viel spaß
so muss aber vorher unbedingt eine
physalis essen und dann ertrinken
[Musik]
packen sie aber nicht ich glaube mich
mit dieser whisky eigentlich überhaupt
nicht gut war
wichtig ist es seien eher wirklich
ungelogen schmid mappus immer mit zahlen
sind wir unglücklich
er ist gut aber da hat schon bessere
guckte gemacht einmal in meinem leben
mit mir du wir sind so eingenommen von
unseren mittleren gansbaai dieses
typische lied einfach nicht mehr ein
paar momente
auf die liebe chinesische lee harrs oder
mobilen kanal sagt hallo wir haben auch
aus gedreht ja aber auch aus meinen
channel wird wohl das ist absolut
richtig also guckt mal vorbei wenn ihr
wollt denn du hast den wagen bevölkerung
für man gucken sonst hätt du bist also
du bist schon dauergast bei mir aber ich
finde es komisch stein zuschauern zu
sagen was sie will ja aber du bist du
bist quasi wie in meinem wohnzimmer und
wie du es auch gerade wirklich bist und
main kanal ist wieder ein wohnzimmer
also wie mein wohnzimmer und ich lieben
kannst du eigentlich machen willst weil
wir schon so was ist wenn ihr mehr von
vanessa sehen wollt dann schaut doch mal
vorbei
say something arena
[Musik]